[Musique]
m
maurane un nom devenu synonyme des
prémices de la pandémie de covile 19 11
millions d'habitants les premiers au
monde à connaître le confinement en 2020
pendant plus de deux mois officiellement
ici
3869 personnes sont mortes du
coronavirus selon certaines estimations
ce pourrait être jusqu'à trois fois plus
deux ans plus tard aucun cas positif n'a
été enregistré depuis des mois pour les
oranais les jours sombres de la maladie
sont déjà loin
la vie est paisible
l'épidémie ne recommence pas ici tout le
monde respecte bien les règles
on fait encore attention mais on n'a
plus peur la ville est complètement
normal
ou année la ville la plus sûre
maintenant one et la vie des héros ses
habitants sont des héros le courage la
solidarité la victoire c'est surtout de
cela dont les habitants veulent se
souvenir des thèmes qui inspire les
artistes ayant tiennent pas des scènes
traditionnelles à la gloire des oranais
avec cette peinture je veux montrer luxe
et des habitants pendant la pandémie
ce courage et cet esprit de résistance
nous viennent de nos ancêtres
pendant la crise elle faisait partie des
bénévoles pour livrer des médicaments de
la nourriture aider les patients à
trouver un lit le souvenir de la
détresse dans les hôpitaux ne l'a pas
quitté
personne ne parlait
quand je suis arrivée à l'hôpital le
seul son que j'entendais c'était le
bruit des gens qui toussent pas aux rois
pinceaux cette scène m'a fait vraiment
peur j'avais envie de partir mais j'ai
choisi de rester elle soutient le
traumatisme reste mais le discours
officiel insiste sur la résilience c'est
le sujet de ce film
le mélodrame raconte le confinement de
hauranne une version très romancé des
destins de héros ordinaires tous unis
dans la bataille contre le virus le
scénario plaît il est numéro un dans les
six ma chinois depuis sa sortie le 7
janvier
[Musique]
j'ai ressenti beaucoup d'empathie en
voyant le film les soignants dans les
hôpitaux et les bénévoles ont été
extraordinaires
je me suis sentie exactement comme à
l'époque
je l' ai vécu moi-même et ce n'était
vraiment pas facile
ces récits ces histoires de victoires
occulte les zones d'ombré du coc vide 19
aoû ran la ville est-elle le berceau de
la pandémie pas selon les autorités
chinoises elles soutiennent que le virus
viendrait de l'étranger haouran pourtant
des soupçons planent encore sur le
marché lieu de vente d'animaux sauvages
barricadé depuis deux ans et sur le
laboratoire p4 dans lequel serait
étudiée dès coronavirus la chine a
refusé la poursuite de l' enquête de
l'om sur ces zones à l'été 2000 21
l'opacité des autorités empêchent tout
consensus scientifique et toute remise
en question zhang rail est l'un des
derniers à critiquer ouvertement le
gouvernement
son père est mort du co vides il y a
deux ans il a été infectée dans un
hôpital de buran j'en aie l'avait emmené
là pour une opération banale ignorant
alors tout du virus au fooding euros
après la mort de mon père je me suis
renseigné et j'ai appris que le virus
était apparu à goran bien avant que j l
le gouvernement local de lujan n'avait
dissimulé
si j'avais su que le coronavirus exister
à bourg ain je ne serais certainement
pas revenu dans la ville john hayes a
porté plainte contre les institutions
pour ne pas avoir prévenu la population
attend des demandes rejetées malgré les
risques il continue de dénoncer le
silence des autorités
car ni même deux ans après je me sens
très en colère les autorités ont menti
en disant que la maladie était
contrôlable et qu'il n'y avait pas de
transmissions interhumaines
elles ont tout de suite réprimer les
personnes comme li wei liang qui ont osé
se manifester pour avertir
liwan yang médecin lanceur d'alert
devenu une icône c'est l'un des premiers
à signaler une mystérieuse pneumonie
haouran avant d'en mourir d'abord accusé
de propager de fausses rumeurs il est
plus tard réhabiliter face à la colère
des internautes
aujourd'hui encore ces réseaux sociaux
croule sous les hommages
nous ne vous avons pas oubliés
merci pour votre courage
vous êtes mon héros
mais la plupart des lanceurs d'alert de
houra n'ont pas été réhabilités sur ces
vidéos la journaliste citoyenne zhang
jian montrer les hôpitaux débordés et la
vie confinée
un jour nous sommes le 13 mai 2020 je
m'appelle zhongshan
c'est sa dernière vidéo arrêté peu de
temps après et condamné à quatre ans de
prison pour provocation au trouble elle
est aujourd'hui en grève de la faim ses
proches craignent pour sa vie
d'autres lanceurs d'alert ont également
été détenus pendant des mois l'un d'eux
fang il n'a pas réapparu depuis bientôt
deux ans
des témoignages comme effacé de la
mémoire officielle de la pandémie à
mourad